AS YOU ALL KNOW HILLARY CLINTON
HAS SET HER SIGHTS ON 1600
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE.
DID YOU KNOW SHE OPENED HER
CAMPAIGN HEADQUARTERS IN ONE OF
NEW YORK'S COOLEST BOROUGHS,
BROOKLYN.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CROOKLYN OR
AS HILLARY CALLS IT BROOKLYN.
OUR BROOKLYN NATIVE MIKE YARD
TOOK TO THE STREETS TO HEAR
HOW EXCITED EVERYONE IS ABOUT
THE NEW NEIGHBOR.
>> HILLARY CLINTON HAS CHOSEN
BROOKLYN FOR HER PRESIDENTIAL
HEADQUARTERS. I GREW UP IN
BROOKLYN, HILLARY, AND
I'M HERE TO HELP YOU FIT IN.
BROOKLYN IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE PLACES IN AMERICA.
YOU GOT YOUR BEARDED HIPSTERS
AND BEARDED JEWS OVER THERE
YOUR RUSSIAN MOBSTERS OVER THERE
BLACK PEOPLE HERE, MORE BLACK
PEOPLE THERE, IF YOU GO FURTHER
OUT MORE BLACK PEOPLE.
EVERYONE HAS A DIFFERENT WAY TO
WELCOME TO YOU TOWN.
LET'S SEE WHAT THEY GOT.
>> ANY FASHION OR BEAUTY ADVICE
FOR HILLARY CLINTON FITTING IN
BROOKLYN?
>> GOT TO GO.
>> NOT IN BROOKLYN.
>> THE EARRINGS HAVE TO SAY,
YES.
LOOK AT ME.
>> JUST LIKE THAT.
>> YES.
>> I WANT TO BE PRESIDENT.
>> GET THE JEWELRY.
NAILS DONE SHORT.
NOT TOO LONG.
I THINK SO NO.
>> DO LIKE HILLARY CLINTON.
>> I LOVE HER SO MUCH.
>> GIVE HER A GOOD PRICE.
>> FREE.
>> DOES THAT MEAN I GET FREE.
I'M HER NEPHEW
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> FREE NAILS FOR HILLARY
THE RICH JUST KEEP
GETTING RICHER. OW!
>> BILL CLINTON'S WIFE COMING
HERE TO MAKE BROOKLYN BETTER.
>> I LIKE HOW YOU SAY BILL
CLINTON'S WIFE AND NOT HILLARY
CLINTON. SHE HAS A NAME.
>> I KNOW.
>> HOW DO YOU MAKE HER A
BROOKLYNITE. WHAT WOULD BE
YOUR ADVICE. IF YOU WANT TO BE A
BROOKLYN GIRL
>> SHE'S GOTTA GET A BROOKLYN
HAT.
NETS HAT AND THEN COME BY SOME
SOCKS FOR $5.
ALL DAY, BILL WILL LIKE THESE ON
HER IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU GIVE HER ANY
PRODUCT THAT WOULD SAY, THIS IS
BROOKLYN?
>> I DON'T KNOW GET HER LIKE A
SCULLY OR A MASK.
>> LIKE A SKI MASK?
>> YEAH.
>> I'M NOT SETTING HER UP FOR A
ROBBERY.
>> GOT TO COME HARD IN BROOKLYN,
HILLARY, WHICH MEANS THE INK
HAS TO BE RIGHT. MAYBE A NICE
NECK TATTOO, BABY DADDY .
OR GO STRAIGHT UP BROOKLYN.
ANYTHING BROOKLYN?
>> COUNTY OF KINGS.
>> ON THE BELLY.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN COMING HERE FOR
HOW LONG?
>> I AM 78.
WE USED TO COME HERE WHEN I WAS
15 YEARS OLD.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON MOVING HER
PRESIDENTIAL HEADQUARTERS TO
BROOKLYN?
>> EVERYONE WAS IN THEIR PLACE
AND GOOD.
YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU GUYS.
YOU GUYS --
>> YOU GUYS MEANING BLACK
PEOPLE.
>> YEAH.
>> SAY IT.
>> WE'RE ACCEPTING BLACK NOW.
>> OH, LARRY.
HOW COME YOU AIN'T GOT NO
BROTHERS ON THE WALL.
I THINK SO WE'RE HERE AT CONEY
ISLAND OUTSIDE OF NATHAN'S
FRANKS, HOME OF THE BEST HOT
DOGS. HILLARY,
IF YOU WANT TO WIN BROOKLYN'S
RESPECT COME DOWN HERE AND DOWN
35 HOT DOGS IN TEN MINUTES.
BRINGING THE WOMENS TITLE BACK
TO AMERICA.
IF YOU DO THAT WE WILL LOVE YOU
FOREVER, HILLARY
>> WE'RE HERE IN THE BEST PART
OF BROOKLYN, EAST NEW YORK
MY HOME. I'M HERE AT EL & JOHN'S
BARBER SHOP. THIS IS WHERE YOU
NEED TO COME TO IF YOU NEED
A SHAPE UP. THIS IS THE SPOT.
WHAT HAIR CUT DO YOU SUGGEST FOR
HILLARY?
>> SHE CAN GET JESUS CHRIST IN
THE BACK OF THE HEAD.
THERE.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
CHRISTIANS WON'T VOTE FOR A
WOMAN WITH JESUS IN THE BACK OF
HER HEAD.
>> WE ARE PUTTING TOGETHER GIFT
BASKET FOR HILLARY TO WELCOME
HER TO BROOKLYN. DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING WE CAN PUT IN THERE?
>> I HAVE ONE, A GIFT
CERTIFICATE FOR ONE FREE SHAPEUP
>> ONE SHAPEUP.
DON'T BE BRINGING A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE FOR EXTRA SHAPEUPS
THIS IS ONE SHAPEUP FOR HILLARY
CLINTON, ONLY.
>> PLEASE SHOW UP, HILLARY.
>> THANK YOU, BROOKLYN LOVES
YOU.
>> WE LOVE THANK YOU.